what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
kevin samuels clip that one of my
followers suggested
um he sent it to me on instagram my
instagram link is in the description
and if you guys have any clips that
you'd want to recommend to me send them
to me on
instagram that is the best way to get a
hold of me
and do not forget to like comment and
subscribe
especially subscribe as you know trying
to hit 15 000
subscribers this week and i'm really
really close i have nothing planned
though
it's like a you know
surprise at 15 000. if you have any
ideas though you let me know
is your price too high no i don't feel
like it's too high at all
okay uh what do you want um
you know i feel like i watch you and i
listen to everything that you say
and i mean i want a man that's
definitely going to be able to pay the
bills
like take care of me um but i still want
to be able to have the option to work
and do like my career have a career
and still have kids how many children do
you want
phil okay so you want it all
yeah yeah where do you live
i'm in north georgia like when she's
pretty
like she's pretty i think okay
are you currently seeing somebody right
now looking pay your bills
no not at the moment when was the last
relationship you had
my last relationship was about three
years ago i was with him for six years
and why didn't you guys get married for
six years
six um i met him in college and that was
my first boyfriend
and so yeah i think we just went through
a lot
and um by the time we got to the end
where we could possibly make something
work
it just did not work
okay how much money is man going to need
to make to be able to pay all the bills
for a family of four in
atlanta atlanta um probably well over
400
okay do you care if he's black or not
yeah yeah but he will the more
400 for two kids okay
median income i'm gonna google this
really quick
money mentioned to make the more
racially loyal they tend to be
okay what percentage of men in this
country make 400 000
or more it was probably like
she froze on me oh okay median income in
atlanta is 34
000 average number
of kids in atlanta
uh i can't find that stat
what percentage of men in this country
make over twenty thousand dollars
um i would say maybe two to four percent
probably not a lot
one okay one percent
so let's go back to what you said i feel
which is kryptonite
men don't care about what you feel we we
think
act and do you want it all
at 28 years old with no men
in the pipeline and you want a top
one percent man what does he
what is the man who make the kind of
money you're talking about making what
do those men typically want from a woman
but for real 400k
does middle class just not exist to
kevin samuels
um you the beauty
probably yeah come um i wouldn't say
submission is that the tv or something
yeah probably is i teach
now the number one thing that men like
that tend to want is cooperation
and the man who's making 400 000 a year
what age do you think men make that
legally
uh well over 35 well over 35 men hit
that financial street
stride between 45 and 55.
are you prepared to marry a man who's 45
years old or older
no so you're a delusional black woman
you don't have any of this in your life
you don't have it in the pipeline
and not only do you want a man who's the
top one percent you want him to be
closer to your age
and then you want him to want what you
want to know right
so if this is just a math problem
it seems to me that you don't know these
men
well i feel like i date men that
um are ambitious maybe i feel like or do
you
more so in my age and then i've started
to recently date a lot older men
but you just get past the question i you
don't know
these men no i don't know those men that
make 500k
no do you don't even know what they
typically want they typically want a
traditional wife
which means your career
that's due respect uh
why do you need it if you're not paying
any bills
i mean i still want my own sense of
like being of who i am by a dog
damn see careers are for outcomes
so you want it to look like i got my own
sense your sense can be to be
a wife to a productive competitive
successful man
and a successful mother to two children
why is that not enough
why can i not have my career and have my
kids and my friends do not qualify
what makes me unqualified you don't know
these men
you don't even know what they want it's
so interesting because
my parents have i have nine siblings
and my parents
like they they do like really well for
themselves so they don't
like i don't know on paper our family
kind of looks like perfect on the
outside and but my mom had like a full
career
and like so did my dad and it was fine
they don't want what you want
traditionally but they met when they
were my mom was
18 and my dad was like
four or five years older
you can want it but this is where it
comes right down to what makes you not
qualified
when these when i talk to these men they
don't want modern women
again you want your husband to be making
400 plus thousand dollars
who's going to raise your children why
are you what is your career a media
correspondent
okay so um
when you are off on site where are the
children going to be
uh daycare so somebody else is going to
be raising
his legacy
no then he might as well marry the nanny
see this is this modern power couple
no the most men don't work
70 80 100 hours with 20 plus years
to go marry a woman to just
carry their children to allow a stranger
to raise them
that's what my parents did this is
interesting because
my household growing up like both of my
parents worked
and it was like fine
i mean there were pros and cons of it of
course but it was fine
right so
father mary are your mother and father
mary yes they are okay
um was your father the majority great
winner
what did your mother do um she does
admin
stuff but both well my mom is they're
both from jamaica so
coming over here she used to do um
coventry healthcare so she used to do
clerical stuff for them
okay but your mother worked outside of
the house
all right do you have much respect for
housewives
i do it's a full-time job i have close
friends that are doing that
okay but the kind of men you're talking
about would want a housewife
more often than not
and if we're honest where
what is the height what is the level you
at the end of your career where would
you like it to be
um my goal right now is to be like a
genie mine
i want to be a personality that people
come and listen to my opinions
and jeannie my on talk shows yes
do you know about how her first marriage
turned out i did
i do is she talking anything like you
now
not now no exactly because it doesn't
work
but she's still able to have a
relationship and be a media
correspondent
uh ma'am she's talking nothing like
you're talking now
i don't know who that is nothing
see your
priority and you're free to choose it
is your your your media is going to be
more important than your man and your
family
i don't know any men who actually have
made themselves the kind of men you're
talking about
who are not going they're number one
their purpose is number two you're
number three
this is you're looking basically you
look the kind of man you're looking for
would drive you up a wall a beta male
provide a beta male
would allow a woman to be on top or be
equal and he's making all that money
um i think you kind of i think you may
have kind of
figured what i was going to say does
kevin samuels not
think that you can have a successful
marriage if a woman has a career
let me know in the comments yeah but
what makes you special
where you can get this well i just i
mean i've listened to a lot of your
things that you say and you say that
these men look for women that are
attractive take care of themselves she
does and
are submissive and i feel like i do hold
a lot of those characteristics
okay there and there are thousands of
you right
so you're attracted to granted take care
of yourself granted
there are also women who are raised to
be first ladies
wives not wanting to challenge
you want you want equality you want your
own identity
then go work for your then marry then
your your
your man is the institution because you
gotta understand
if you have and let's say you and i were
married
you're not making millions and you're
making what
i would assume just as close to that
no no no media correspondence
from whom depends on our land
right uh for every genie mine come on
most of the journalists that i knew in
school they had to work free internships
journalists are some of the brokeest
people in the world oh i know
so let's not cat okay you're talking
about
trying to be in the top one tenth of a
one percent most journalists
broke his french toast so
ernie what
before your big break before my big
break i would say probably 15.
50. baby girl that's a that's
the kind of minion 50 to a man is making
400
that's that's less that's just over ten
percent of what he's making
what do you guys think that girls like
that that want a career should do
um do you guys think
that
they should just forego kids all
together or do you think
that they just need to find a beta male
but everyone
they call they throw around the term
beta male so loosely they call like 80
of men betas it will cost more to hire
than nannies
new child infant care is two thousand
dollars a month
so if you had a one and a three-year-old
you're looking at three thousand dollars
so my question kevin though is so
because i've had a fork in the road
where i either need to pick my career or
pick
whether i want to be a housewife great
so it's getting into the rooms of being
in or being into the face of the men
that i want to be in front of
right and um
i don't know how to kind of articulate
what i'm trying to say but it's more so
like
i've been in front of men that make a
lot of money and
i feel like i could still do both at the
same time
well that's what you feel i have kids
that's what you feel
let's see and i'll be i'm gonna just be
dead honest with you
the leverage is on this side right not
yours
both men will date you both men will
sleep with you
only neither will marry you
that's just what it comes down to
neither will marry you
so what it is is what we haven't got to
you're coming from a place of you're
projecting fear
scarcity and lack that's why you need to
have your career and everything else
because what if my marriage doesn't work
what's this what that what if i get lost
doing all sorts of stuff
so really
a man at this level would just be hiring
you
for your dna but
the way i would look at that
is not so much the
like some girls just genuinely like i
just genuinely like like doing this
stuff
i enjoy it you know so
it's interesting to me that he thinks
that all women or that like at least her
that she does it because
she only she only wants like
like a scarcity mindset he'd be hiring
you
to impregnate you for you to carry the
child
to make the child and then someone else
will go raise that child
while you're off being a media
correspondent fulfilling your purpose
and dream that's not what these men
typically want
but let's be honest do you really
think that are you really coming from a
place where you think your marriage is
going to last for 40 50 years
yeah i surely do okay then who
then why would you want someone else to
raise your children
i think i've seen my mom do both
so i'm assuming that i can
also accomplish that my mom did both too
i mean children this is my man just me
there we go the only child syndrome
no baby girl okay no no yes you're i
mean you're an attractive woman
that ain't enough oh i mean and and what
you're telling me
ma'am if i put you in a room with these
men
you you fast realize how
out of step with your competition you
really are just by the
femininity these ladies exude their
willingness to be
the first lady
versus you would more likely be over the
conversation with the men
wanting to exchange opinions
yeah yeah that would make great sex
but no thank you so
you have to ask yourself a question
what's
if that's most important to you
then you're talking about a completely
different kind of man
you're talking about a man who's making
closer to 50 70 000
a year if you're fortunate
could you respect the man making that
kind of money
um because but you're also talking about
a quality of life to where
you making 50 he's making 70 y'all
living in a
you're not living the bucket you're not
driving bmw you driving honda civics
michael you're not going to hear me as
in dior don't be going over shops and
buggy
okay number one i i got two two points
my family's wealthy we never drove nice
cars and we never
went bought designer like clothes other
than lulu but that's not like
high-end designer there's different
types of rich people and i can just tell
that kevin samuels is the type of rich
person that
spends money on like what i would say is
like
designer things and like like a
corporate
millionaire there's like the corporate
millionaires and then there's like
the millionaires that go make their
money own their small business
and really don't talk to people or care
what anyone else thinks
yeah every now and then y'all may be
able to go to papa though
on your anniversary or something right
can you really live that life i don't
think so
exactly i'm looking at you now so the
thing is man
i feel so sorry for so many of our young
sisters because you all
want this inflated lifestyle and that's
fine to want it
but the kind of men you would want to
date a man that's 45
well then who else is going to make
money an athlete entertainer
or a musician or d boy
what's a d boy what this shows more
anything else is
mine and women focus so much on who they
are
and the world has let you guys do this
on what you want
to where you have to focus nothing on
who the men actually are
what the men actually want so
you don't mean to but you're really
dissing a whole group of men
by pedestalizing this group of men but
you're not even giving these people they
want
right and sadly so many of our sisters
are
stuck in this position because of the
ego and the pride that comes along with
what you're talking about is not as
though
yes there are women who can't do both
but jenny mine has no children
yeah and her first marriage failed
miserably because she was
didn't want kids and he did he went off
and got married had kids
so and then complicate this with being
an only child kind of thing
like i'm moving parts there man a lot of
moving parts i don't believe in only
children
like i genuinely think if you have one
kid you should have two
okay i think you need i think you need
to take some real time to figure out
really what you need not what you want
what you want may be one thing but what
do you
need because of your people your family
are from jamaica
i mean ain't like you grew up with a
silver spoon in your mouth
why are you so busy now
uh you just you know as i've gotten
older i've learned to spoil myself so
why women waste so even like the nails
okay let me know in the comments because
it's mostly men that watch my channel
do you guys think like eyelash
extensions fake nails hair dye
all that stuff helps improve a woman's
appearance dramatically
because i think it helps slightly but
it's not worth the money invested into a
house
who's money or a trip my own money
making 50 000 a year i mean i have
so during the day i still work in real
estate
and then of course as a media
correspondent i have to pick up my gigs
on the weekends
but it's still next to a certain amount
of money right
are you how you spoiling yourself
without the money
i'ma spoil myself because i mean
you roll up in the cartier and it is
what it is
like credit card debt can you do that
at 28 on your income no
no then you can't support yourself baby
girl
but you but see the confidence in which
so many young professional sisters talk
is like well
it's just like i mean almost like you're
coming off as though
i don't want to use the word impostor
but it's like what are you talking about
i mean i don't want to get caught into
how much his savage
but 28 a media correspondent you make
i would assume you're between 40 and 75
and that's being generous and that's
what all your gigs
and they say that happiness i think it's
75 or 80 k a year that your happiness
really doesn't go up past that
everything else
right that's a nice apartment and a car
note
that's be able to go to the bill of okay
every now and then
but really
men with that you date
will probably pick up the slack but
that's fine they're going to want
something for that
so if you end up being closer to the
norm
for media correspondence closest to the
median income not the jenny mines
because you know that's the far the
exception right if you look at everybody
on their panel lonnie love does not look
like one of the happiest people in the
world and she got a broken
painter
but and london you know you talk a lot
[ __ ] about black men so you got it
coming
well you usually you gotta reform jeezy
uh but if you stick closer to
what most people make that means you're
not going to be making
over six figures do you really want to
go
the rest of your life because you need
to be independent in your sense of self
to where you end up 50 years old
with the middling career there's a
correspondent news here this such and so
forth i mean you
you're doing okay but you can't travel
and go to paris and it's not on your own
money
right what does that look like
after you're no longer able to sit in
the anchor chair
but you know you all gonna have this
youthful view but they bring in the next
women what does that look like because
then you can't turn around
and try to be like well now i already
get married no no no no you
too oh yeah in the danger zone for a
reason this is the age where you ladies
really have to make up your mind
either i'm going to couple with the man
of value and i'm going to figure
something out or i'm going to go this
life by myself
and i'm going to take what it gives me
and this path
is not one i recommend because it's help
highly competitive you know and no one's
going to give you anything
and this path tends to end up in a lot
of loneliness
um so unless you know
you are 100 willing to commit
and that means cutting off marriage and
kids and all the other stuff because
to make this work you can't serve two
masters you got to pick a side
i hate to break it that way but just
think about it just think about it
but you can't have everything can't have
it all
it's interesting because i grew up
in a family where my mom literally did
like i mean she worked like for my dad
so i guess
i guess in a way maybe
but she really liked her career like she
really
she like was in charge of all the sales
of the company that my dad started
so i don't know let me know in the
comments if you think and now she's like
writing books and stuff
and we had nannies and it was fine so
let me know in the comments if you think
it's like wrong
to have nannies growing up and if you
think that would be a lifestyle you'd
you would be okay with and you would be
okay with for your kids
and don't forget to like comment and
subscribe i will talk to you guys
next time